außerirdische lebensformen und das nicht
nur im all sondern sogar direkt bei uns
auf der erde
die britische ex astronauten und
chemikerinnen helen hahmann ist fest
davon überzeugt dass es zitat da draußen
alle möglichen arten von lebensformen
geben muss und sie hat auch eine idee
warum es uns bisher nicht gelungen ist
diese aufzuspüren klicks um science
fiction die jetzt täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen sie waren nicht nur
die erste britische frau im all sondern
die erste britische person überhaupt
hellen räumen ein radiospot vor 31
jahren 1989 hatte sie inspiriert sich
als astronautin zu bewerben
und tatsächlich aus 13.000 bewerberinnen
und bewerbern bekamen sie letztendlich
die zusage zwei jahre später startete
sie dann mit zwei politischen
kosmonauten zur raumstation müll und
blieb dort sechs tage lang hier kümmerte
sie sich um experimente unter anderem in
den bereichen medizin und
agrarwissenschaften mittlerweile ist sie
dozentin und tv-kommentatoren doch ihren
flug in den weltraum wird sie nie
vergessen dazu sagt sie in einem
interview mit der britischen
sonntagszeitung observer den weltraum zu
sein hat mich gelehrt dass es auch
menschen ankommt nicht auf materielle
güter dort oben hatten wir alles was wir
zu überleben brauchten die richtige
temperatur essen und trinken sicherheit
ich dachte nicht an die gegenstände die
ich auf der erde besitze wenn wir über
bestimmte teile der welt flogen dachten
wir immer an unsere lieben unter uns die
ex astronauten und chemikerinnen hat
zudem eine ganz klare meinung zum thema
außerirdische dass es sie im all gibt
steht für sie fest dazu sagt sie in
einem guardian interview außerirdische
existieren es gibt keinen zweifel daran
es gibt so viele milliarden von sternen
da draußen im universum dass es alle
möglichen arten von lebensformen geben
muss die entscheidende frage dabei
warum haben wir sie trotz intensiver
suche bislang noch nicht aufgespürt auch
dazu hat helen schauen einen möglichen
erklärungsansatz es ist möglich dass sie
schon hier sind und wir sie einfach
nicht sehen können
die chemikerin geht nämlich nicht davon
aus dass außerirdische lebensform
genauso aufgebaut sind wie wir heißt
also im klartext diese müssen nicht
unbedingt ausstieg und kohlenstoff
bestehen so wie wir und auch das
restliche leben auf der erde ein
die so auch von anderen forschenden in
betracht gezogen wird möglicherweise
könnte sie nie ziehung statt kohlenstoff
eine art basis für leben sein denn
silizium und kohlenstoff ähneln sich von
ihren eigenschaften weil der elemente
gehören zur vierten haupt gruppe des
periodensystems und haben somit vier
äußere elektronen die chemische bindung
eingehen können ähnliche reaktionen sind
in der theorie also quasi
vorprogrammiert doch sie nie zum
verbindungsstellen sich im vergleich als
deutlich starre heraus und genau das
macht es wieder ein bisschen
unwahrscheinlicher dass daraus
intelligentes leben entstehen könnte so
oder so die wissenschafts community ist
davon überzeugt dass außerirdische
existieren und die nasa geht davon aus
dass sie in den nächsten jahrzehnten
auch gefunden werden oder zumindest der
erste kontakt hergestellt werden kann
und wenn wir auch nur mikroben auf einen
gestirn in unserem sonnensystem finden
aber auch das wäre einfach nur meint
lohnen denn damit wäre klar dass das
weltall ein einziger brutkasten ist und
überall leben existiert und vielleicht
auch zwischen den sternen systemen hin
und herfliegt wir hatten ja letztlich
darüber berichtet dass die verbindung
auf denen unser leben basiert in einem
außerirdischen meteoriten auf unserer
erde gefunden worden es ist schon
verrückt aber eben mit solchen kunden
auch immer wahrscheinlicher dass wir
schon bald auf leben da draußen stoßen
werden aber wie nehmen wir kontakt auf
zu zivilisationen die weiter entfernt
sind außerirdische mega zivilisationen
finden so könnte es gehen anklicken
anschauen und neugier zu harmonieren
richtig cooler cannabis dann bleibt dran